and are we living I can't I I hear the
stuff I read this stuff and I think
people are operating in parallel
universes if you don't like Trump that's
your prerogative but you actually have
to make a coherent argument based on
facts okay and most of you folks on the
left are just embittered and angry and
delusional at this point now I asked
about the twilight zone whether we're
living in it because the same media
outlets who felt for the ridiculously
phony obviously phony steel dossier are
now embracing the founders of the firm
behind the steel dossier fusion GPS so
Glenn Simpson and Peter fridge are
promoting their new book and NBC of
course gave them a lot of questions like
well how does it feel what's your
favorite color
watch the Republicans controlled
Washington for two years all of
Washington for two years and they used
that time to investigate the
investigators and dig into us and waste
enormous amounts of money trying to find
something on us that would discredit us
we were not able to talk about those
things for a long time and in the
meantime faced a lot of pressure from
Republicans in Congress specifically the
chairman of the Judiciary Committee and
the House Intelligence Committee Devon
Nunez sure what he mumbled at the end
there but here to respond Devon Nunez
ranking member in the house Intel
committee and Lee Smith investigative
journalist author of the plot against
the president a fantastic book
congressman fusion GPS actually ran a
campaign against you in 2018 so what do
you think of their winding and mourning
oh they were mean to us they were so
mean to us and the kid glove treatment
they were getting over at NBC well look
it's typical whatever they accuse you of
doing they're actually doing so even the
title of their book is hilarious right
because they're the ones that are
continuing the crimes and so I think
part of what this book is about is not
to sell a bunch of copies it's to get
out ahead of the lawsuits that are
coming so they knew that we were through
discovery that we were going to discover
that they were behind all the smears on
me and that's that's what's clear about
the book and that was going to come out
in the court cases anyway Lee what do
Amer
Ekans watching tonight have to
understand about this duo infusion GPS I
mean you documented this better than
anyone about what was done especially
the congressman newness without whom
President Trump might not be in the
current a good position he's in but his
his work has been just unbelievable but
what do people have to understand is
this just another consulting group
another research firm in DC or something
quite different this is something quite
different and if you look at these
different clips on NBC when they're
speaking with Chuck Todd and with Rachel
Maddow it looks rather more like a
ransom we have we'll see it looks like a
hostage video because all of the media
organizations they weren't just tricked
they were complicit in what's going on
so if you look at their faces they have
to put their message through and the
media is going to take the media is
gonna take it and they're going to work
with them to shape this narrative now
with Horowitz and Durham bar coming out
as well it's very important for them to
get this message out and try to shape it
all right as Lee mentioned it is very
noteworthy that the fusion GPS founders
went to NBC first now why was that
important because the host would bend
over backwards to basically give them
well kind of like an interview style
foot rub their new book is called crime
in progress it's really good I feel
fairly steeped in this matter and I
learned something on every page you guys
have been through hell and high water
what kind of toll is this taken out on
you guys personally the book it is a
fascinating rate no matter with what you
think of the steel dossier if you talk
about it you should read this book so
why NBC well a few years ago Lee wrote
about a connection between a specific
NBC reporter infusion GPS explain that
briefly when we get back to Congress
yeah this is about Ken Delaney and over
at NBC and when he was attacking William
Browder as part of an operation on
behalf of the Russian government he
appeared to be reciting talking points
provided by fusion GPS so there are long
connect there are extensive connections
between fusion GPS and the entire media
and NBC is certainly a part of it
Congressman Nunez at this point we know
that the Nadler crew is going to get two
weeks of their own whatever they're
going to end up doing with this
impeachment nonsense what do you expect
to happen he's already threatening MSA
so everyone who missed the last you know
few minutes of the show there he's
threatening the President of the United
States with unspecified penalties if he
doesn't show up to testify what this is
this is where we've gotten okay I cannot
imagine how a constitutional hearing
next week about the constitutionality of
impeachment how that's going to be any
better for them than the last two weeks
when they had dud after dud after dud of
witnesses so Nadler at least evidently
he's been found because the guy's been
missing since you know before the
summertime right nobody's seen him they
ripped him off the stage so I can't
imagine my guess is they're gonna have
like one hearing next week and then
they'll vote the following week I just
can't imagine they're going to leave
them up for multiple hearings and have
another you know where all the networks
cover these guys it'll make it it'll
drive their numbers even lower than they
are today
well again I want to say that having you
both on together is a treat because
congressman I remember when you were
being smeared when they were claiming
you were conflicted out of the whole
Russia thing there was lying about that
for I don't know how long that was I was
still doing my radio show ace to have
you on about that and and then it was
the yeah all the stuff just made-up
nonsense ly you took it upon yourself to
write about this and and to explain it
in a way and it does I mean I'm sound
like I'm sucking up to you know but it
it's so important for people to
understand that it's not just what you
read in the headlines you have to dig
into the facts of what they do to good
people to try to rip them to shreds and
it's critical I mean while this uh Peter
Frisch guy was speaking I guess on Meet
the Press about the parallels between
Russia and impeachment I got to get you
both quickly on this watch I was sitting
here today at the end of 2019 does
anyone doubt that Donald Trump would be
capable of inciting a foreign or working
with a foreign government
to affect the political process here in
this country it's exactly what the house
is looking at right now
congressman Nunez really quickly thought
yeah they're the ones that went to
foreigners they took money from the
Democrats and went to Ukrainians and
Russians to dig up dirt on Trump I mean
these guys are a complete joke they're a
racketeering operation and they need to
be shut down they're very dangerous for
democracy I thank both of you for being
with us tonight
Lee and Congressman Nunez thank you and
Congressman Nunez I know you're gonna
get a tie back on laughter when you come
back to work he's always at the expo
that Expo must be going on World fo x
okok Gerson you're back on you're always
at this Expo what is it you mean every
time I have you want there's like trucks
in the back it's by my mouth it's by my
house and then they've got nice colorful
background and it's museum so it's not
actually going on now it's I'm a little
slow before Thanksgiving I appreciate it
but if the Christmas theme color is
behind you all right thanks so much
Happy Thanksgiving